yeah mmm you hello and welcome to this
video this is a new three-minute madness
so let's get mad huh let's see what we
can do going to play shop stuff this is
a try yeah okay so we've got some
Sicilian images I think quite a good
start
to get something rolling okay maybe five
he's not developing so oh wow ready okay
that that looks like a good start for
some madness night will go to be seven
that looks crazy and I'm going to fire
right away 96 many here we go okay if he
takes it with the pawn I'll take g7 and
play Queen h5 check aha aha so that felt
too dangerous right check okay this is
also going to be dangerous that much is
clear
it should be a pretty good position for
white mister Chavo Queen age five Jack
here we go that doesn't look very
healthy rook f7 let's fire yeah this
should be seven doesn't look very good
either
yeah but this I have a hard time to
believe in what you do him hmm can check
their on g5 or h4 mmm now that itself
it's a pretty good position in many many
ways I think this is good actually
let's have an eye here on d7 and I'm
threatening Bishop b4 yeah which is
pretty difficult to meet but should be
45 Bishop t5 winds the winds the Queen
okay yeah well here Bishop g5 was my
idea but hmm it's got King yet is that
still not losing it's hard to believe
her but should she 558 so I don't have a
wind it's it's weird okay
hmm it's not a move then I love to play
check this is a little bit better now
check me next move black okay next we
start mark with David
that's a GM right that's Kumar squash a
burrito or something like that
yep mr. Kumar Abrego yeah I've got white
diamond so I should move
oh we went back to to g8 hey I'm the
wild man here what are you doing
check okay so we got some unconventional
position here pretty much I know it's
tough
okay he gives me the exchange I'm going
to take it I kind of surprising okay
well he's got this this kind of this
kind of central player which is
definitely yeah not to be ignored
let's do this I had 46 yeah he tries to
take on b2 so I would play Bishop b3
yeah yeah it might take that so I'm I
would go here for f3 lady for move also
helps me to open up the position quickly
yeah here I have no big choice I have to
support it and now f3 that's III
unfortunately which is a bit of a shame
yeah still am this and f3 I need to open
up the position there is no big doubt
damn also I want to get a system and get
out as king I mean this is the the point
of this whole console show concept go
for the throat directly okay so I'm here
we go
it's very dangerous
I think for him this one yeah I've got
rookie 3 you know I guess so to be form
yeah he's preventing 24 I think and the
text g3 it's bit annoying maybe here
covering this and keeping loop t7 as an
option rock g7 is it's not clearly a
threat oh it is a threat yeah head Queen
eh oh this is actually a big threat
which is not attending to okay
Chang oh nine evade home sorry I'm sorry
that is actually not not a clear win I
always looked at the bishop is covering
this year oh that's a bit of a shame
Queen age seven
not good not good
and yes some he has a shiny chicks he
has a couple of checks I can check here
that the change is seven and it's not
really doing much ninety six is Quincy
dream check I know it's got Bishop g7
what what do I do what am I doing here
it's stupid it's stupid
I just forgot that yes I thought its key
yet ah stupid stuff and I have no move
him now that was bad like probably quite
just winning position I don't believe it
it should hold them and I enter only
seven and so on but I simply overlooked
that I'm having no checkmate him here
that this I thought this is a checkmate
Queeny Queeny 8j Queenie sixes is of
course too strong I can I can win this I
saw that I thought this is checkmate but
this is covering h7 so it's a pretty
pretty stupid I'm pretty stupid plane
otherwise I don't even take on this out
I mean I'm not I don't want to draw here
yeah okay I wondered game actually don't
get one by the way the computer shows
the a5 is completely winning intending
night h7 but this is not exactly it is
he oh come on give me a game yet what is
what is going on him not many people are
starting okay Kendu virus I am okay
let's go for for the Dutch it still it's
tough to get something real creo it's
just Bishop f4 really that's your idea
of some madness yeah okay
yeah I need to get in some f5 yeah right
Queeny aids doesn't look good and that
b5 is coming so I'm going to wait a
little bit here and see what he's doing
it's not flying very aggressively anyway
we can still play 95 I know if just this
is a good move of course but what can
you do no it's it's not so bad for black
this Bishop on each tooth doesn't make
any sense here yeah I probably give or
take yeah this is this position is
totally falling for black nothing bad
happening this feels quite okay for me
not sure night before you might have 95
no yeah it's okay anyway his Bishop on
h2 is not looking very good d4 a Bishop
f4 is not exactly an opening where you
can know yeah get some madness going I
don't want to play something totally
totally bad okay no no he allows me to
trade which I don't want to do
yeah but okay if I take Jim hmm it's
it's rather equal issue and hmm okay
yeah his bishops soon looking quite
stupid but it's not much going on it's
the thing yeah maybe I can't get my King
involved him and of course I have this
which I probably should have played
earlier
okay um Bishop Bishop here chick chick
on c3 it doesn't help much
okay I can do this though under
undermining his paw Neville if he takes
d5 it's as good as gone whenever I can I
can now yeah I guess b5 friend takes
root d5 is good no it looks fine d5 pawn
should be check should be falling and it
is falling yeah no I think I can accept
the trade check okay now with the 556 as
a King and pawn ending should be should
be winning oops
when I guess e5 right check check
you cannot move as king over to the
Queen side as then I'm going to promote
miss G for something here on time
warning it is actually not so easy
wait didn't play that well right it's
not that easy I don't have a good move
him that's crazy
G for this g3 Wow okay we have our movin
on time here but very weird and I didn't
Adam for it that I didn't ever even move
them what is that not winning here it's
hard to believe I have to go h5 for us
this is this is a mistake really looks
totally normal but I have to do this
first and then g5 okay oh okay yeah I
need some more craziness d4 Bishop f4 is
really is a completely game started
wrong start House of fun yeah can you go
d4 here buddy okay how which five that
was close
okay here we can get some get some
craziness going mmm this one why is that
good okay check yeah it should be it
should be fine for me just by normal
means no craziness
yeah just opening up the position he's
giving me the bishop parent in the
process weakened the dark squares this
is a five minute game I was old my has a
five minute game hmm
this is not really that was really not
was boom look that wasn't intended right
okay let's win this game and ask
questions later okay let's go over here
giant looks pretty good huh should be a
very good position for black the an-94
service is coming him I wonder I wonder
I wonder I wonder if I should cover it I
think I should cover it actually yeah
this is I've got dominated him right
I've got dominated okay I wonder about a
five a five before I think I'm going to
flick that in okay probably Scott a for
just not that bad for him now okay a
five wasn't good to know shouldn't have
played that I mean not a problem or
anything but it's a bad idea to provoke
the smooth which he probably doesn't
mind anyway
and it was a bad idea I don't know what
to do him I wonder if I should just go
p6e or something like that
94 it's also always an option or this
one I can do this one actually try to
push the night even further back yeah
that looks good and the night is
dominated yeah yeah that's a good move I
think
yeah yeah I like it yeah this is wrong
here right this was three million
madness but I just miss clicked I'm so
used to clicking in the five button
instead of the three button so very
strange anyway
yeah g-force the thread pushing the
night even further back man 94 is a move
that I was constantly yeah thinking I
was cause he's thinking it would happen
but it doesn't he doesn't play it
somehow yeah that's possible the whole
time so I guess it's time to take him
and now this is G for business so what
is this if I take now here he has to
take with the rook I guess okay can't
take with the bishop but it's like
passive and to no end
but yeah I'm winning this pawn you know
it looks pretty good
looks strong age five you know I think
going to keep that porn but that is so
nicely limiting its position we have a
wind see five I think it's hotter didn't
see how we can and keep it
guess he cannot okay so let's end
tonight F for the zoo gave eight I'm not
sure if it really happens but okay this
is good dumb fully centralizing I guess
to have to would be cool check first on
can also play d4 here right yeah get
this rolling
yeah chicky on check and check with the
rocker so it should be close to
checkmate why yeah it was not really a
three-minute madness game it was rather
five minutes I don't know but it I think
it was a good game anyway
okay let's get to a new three-minute
game and see what happens and click this
right game started this is so wrong be
okay money for mr. Romm be new name okay
yeah this is this is totally crazy
I'm really just playing
making up things as I go along I have no
idea about the opening might have some
tactic already here I don't know I think
white often also goes to d3 here in this
in this kind of position with the
possible things happening on g6 this is
not happening here thank you
he's got 94 huh it's got 94 year
ah shoot yeah yeah yeah I know so it too
late maybe maybe it's not so easy Bishop
takes 94 and queen if he takes with a
king I'll check only 7 so he wasn't
black yeah you won't see this cracker
I'm winning a piece here that's really
it's really um yeah yeah I'm winning a
piece like that and if you place this I
just take so you blunted a piece so I
was lucky of it or you know lucky yeah
it's not I have no idea about the
opening and then you just reel under the
piece that's cool it's got high rating
in this car too 720 on five minutes what
got to be kidding me
Wow
okay
I should try to let me check three
miniatures two or three 40s my best so I
hope to get down it'll be cool
but I don't even get a game here that's
crazy
that's actually there is some much will
start Giovanni 1964 ok Giovanni
we got a Sicilian again yeah this is
very straightforward you know what's
what's going to happen him what is this
this is really this is really a Lionel
and with this beard hmm okay so I'm
retreating for the moment but now fire
again I'm blundering f4u it okay it's
small change of house and now I can
check here for Bishop fm9 of it I think
I probably did you this first and go
from here a checking now that's probably
not doing that much okay
let's activate this first
and then c95 is now a good firm I guess
but okay didn't do that so it's good for
look everyone maybe here I have a five
maybe takes it takes on b7 yo I should
take that opportunity he doesn't he
absolutely doesn't care right
maybe correctly some but at least I'm
entering in a position now a bit here I
guess look see a town that looks kind of
normal or not rook c8 probably am bishop
a six-foot bishop before it's not easy
for him to play in this position it's
quite messy
there should be five is the idea
disturbing the rook there and getting at
his King he's a pawn up but it doesn't
look so relevant here at the moment okay
yes so I can go Bishop b5 I think I
should do that pretty much regardless if
I get rid of the light squareds bishops
him I will also have chances to attack
on that color complex okay him so what
is this I can check now here don't know
that should be first
check I don't know ticks with a king
year maybe okay now that I check on 84
it looks like a good check check
I would like to play 96 like it made
almost everyone it's not good not really
hmm there's some way okay wonders Bishop
f6 that Sevilla and dislike no but I can
it's not a big deal rook evade is a very
very crude threaten but you never know
it might still okay um well he's not
I don't know 94 looks wrong he cannot
take this then because I mean maybe he
can I don't know I don't know
sorry a tough 2525 is just a check
unfortunately it's not it's not okay see
a good move here I can take on the for
now didn't do it
19 seconds I didn't see that one coming
check ten seconds
doesn't look good
check game okay why why I was a weird
game and no idea what was going on there
maybe it was I mean okay esteem shaky
but he had still a couple of pieces
always around it so hmm kind of weird I
don't believe that this you know after I
had to wanna be seven that decision
this looks favorable for white somehow
but maybe maybe I'm wrong between 94 was
good yeah probably is this very tangled
move here Jenny
here I should have something better
between two a six is given by the comp
yeah this is what's wrong yeah that was
yeah tempted by the one mover this is a
good move intending to play this it
seems yeah yeah no it's dangerous his
King is small in more danger than my
king and currently our kid assesses pawn
is extra pawn it's not not that
convincing
that's very little traffic yet
three-minute pool at the moment I really
wonder why I'm game started violin chess
or something okay come on let's do
something frankly here we go oh it's not
even reacting I think you should react
it a little bit at least know what it
says you can't reload something weird
okay what what the heck
you want to win that pawn white you a
greedy greedy guy just wow yeah I'm
going to go into attack like a complete
lunatic here
okay the knight is hanging it's probably
lunatic right not romantic anyway anyway
yeah and all you're thinking and
thinking about your your greet yeah and
I g1 back and that's the only move that
kind of fits under this into this scheme
Oh
see doing here
hmm yeah this is mysterious Knight g5
looks I don't know weird can't believe
in that moment you have to go back here
what's the deal it's some kind of
disconnection yeah you're not going to
find that position in one of your books
this is just some pretty sure about yeah
that's a but it was spoiler he has
spoilsport that same it's just not
moving I'm okay you never know maybe in
Saudia unrelated to the position or
whatever just yet and someone knocking
at the door things like that but you
never know okay so I can now take them I
wonder what captures better my teases
Queen f3 is kind of annoying and so
maybe like this yeah I've got 95 so I'm
pretty cool about all that so night C to
hang up 795 cannot check here really g6
and f7 is very very very nicely
protected ok mr. Vieau launches whatever
I think I can also do this first
yeah Queen age 5 I have g6 so that's
also not going to be a problem going to
take this track okay um what now just 27
something something easy yeah my knight
and I would like to secure my knight but
it's not going to not going to work like
a piece up even after he takes this card
you have a look up yeah this h5 this is
kind of yeah I know but it's kind of
it's dangerous it's the dangerous in a
blitz game this kind of stuff I think I
would just really play it for him
and now in black edge form hmm I don't
know yeah I'm not saying it's good for
black but it gets gets weird and it is
three minute inside okay discover chess
um maybe I can play this classical touch
no but here I can play this crazy line
again no why Cannot it be four okay h7
then heading in the the five in the
three-minute madness video before that
it was a super crazy game
I'm taking I'm taking absolutely Wow Wow
all of the space that I can get this is
good
you've got to be kidding me
mr. discover chess your dark squares are
completely completely rotten and he's
losing even more Tara I've heard no in
one word no let's see how to how to do
this here
would you like to prevent him from
canceling in the first place and would
be nice for me don't manage but the
bishop to age six is probably cool
he's got c5 huh made him they're taking
this book I should not blunder this book
this is this is something to watch out
for ninety four groups I've got cream g6
okay
bacon mmm they're taking was much much
more interesting this is I don't
understand I can take you for Herod well
what is the deal he takes c6 take this
now it's it's it's it's bad anyway when
it's a bet in many ways this is the
correct way to phrase it
okay I'm taking this okay community eggs
I wouldn't ever have something better
yeah this is too much hanging here
Chaddock too much hanging okay so check
here and stuff check
I have to have to discover the rock
there's no other way you're doing it
okay yeah I'm actually a bit annoyed
that this game is not over yet
it was an extraordinarily good position
and I mean it probably is still good but
it was better than this now no now he
finds moves this is not fair Wow okay
yeah well if you place fancy fancy moves
now I hope to being able to punish this
probably not probably not check
no it's kids pinned it's pinned
yeah that was a shame I mean he's just
using right here this is just completely
awful but I didn't manage to kill him
off there anyway
let's shoot for one more game I mean
what did he do here allowing this is
kind of kind of crazy yeah maybe I can
can do it even better him that that
should be winning and now he does
something yeah I don't know
I wanted you game backs right yes no big
need to analyze this accidentally try it
together okay Zach shake their cheek who
is that
Sarah Gates Agha go now I had sakoku
brothers I don't oops I don't know if
it's there two one one is about 2600 and
the other is even higher rated and so on
pretty strong pretty strong opponent
here okay again this is some Sicilian
line that I have no clue about
yeah that looks kind of we are kind of
normal that same relatively normal line
this threatens night is sick song I'm
not sure with the threat but it's a cool
move okay and now I cannot play it I
mean it's not made what is actually it
is actually almost made it's too funny
not to play it right take screen age 5
and if he takes it it's checkmate it's
really funny so he has to go to e7 FTX
Queen age 5
it seems some that's a surprise to move
it okay check King e7 check and then I
go you 5 this is kind of fun kind of
funky yeah that actually seems to work
crazy
at least I'm not losing material right
away I don't I don't see it at least
okay okay mr. Chicago and if I take this
now check and now Bishop takes this
Knight egg so it's not working
okay okay I'll just take this may it's
too lame or anything but yeah here look
at these seven looks like the move I
think I'm not thinking about this
anymore
I'm just firing okay I can take is six
and he will do there but I can take
Bishop f6
this is looking quite good the Roku
doesn't have a scram
he only has a check Queen a - maybe but
he's got Bishop III check however no
okay okay
this is the idea interesting so c4 I
guess and then you know anyway I'm
playing it okay so if I take the rook
now what is the deal
I can also check on your aid first time
warning probably make some sense check I
give those checks first and see where is
going hey I am this is stronger this is
stronger it doesn't have anything right
now King to b6 maybe I have got to check
here check I am it selected king c5 the
species 7 check check yes I got one here
good good GM here in the final game yeah
that's a funky tactic I think I saw that
motif before it says there should be two
astir it's there's a cool move I mean I
know it's okay it has an idea it has
this 96 idea and he went he allowed the
straightaway and this is at least
dangerous at least it's dangerous I'm
getting
something back at here I'm winning Jiang
Jiang yeah
it's okay
yeah it wins Queenie sixes even even
clear up check but it generates enough
Chang Chang and Queen a7 is made okay
but again if you're gonna win the Queen
take the Queen it's uh it's easier yeah
it was a kind of a wild session as usual
but there was some cool games I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching